[MUSIC PLAYING]
CELESTE NELSON: I'm
inspired by my students.
I'm inspired by the challenges
that they overcome, the ideas
that they come up with.
I'm inspired by my previous
mentors who have not only
inspired me, but many
generations of scientists
as well.
I find inspiration from looking
at the variety of organisms
that we have on
our planet, and how
they achieve their unique forms
and niches that they fill.
I'm Celeste Nelson,
professor of chemical
and biological engineering.
My group is focused on trying
to understand how populations
of cells build the
beautiful structures that we
see in our bodies and
destroy those during disease.
So half of the lab
is focused on what
we call tissue morphogenesis.
That's the process through
which small populations of cells
build themselves into the
intricate architectures
that you see in things like
the airways of the lung,
or the ducts of the
mammary gland, things
that are really complex.
And the other half
the lab is focused
on trying to understand how
those structures are destroyed
during diseases like asthma,
or fibrosis, or cancer
progression.
The way I teach is to come
up with a variety of ways
to explain information to the
entire population of students
that we have.
Some students learn best
listening to lectures
and taking notes,
while others learn best
by hands-on projects.
The fraction of students
who learn well by doing
is, I think,
increasing over time.
And even those who can grasp
material simply by hearing it,
it's reinforced when they
can apply what they've
learned to an actual
problem that they get
to solve with their own hands.
I'm drawn to
beautiful structures
and compelling images.
Many of the techniques
that we use in order
to solve problems or
investigate questions
related to tissue
development or disease
are really quite
visual in nature --
a lot of microscopy,
a lot of imaging.
People in science are,
by nature, quite creative
and see beauty in the subjects
that they're investigating.
The graduate students
challenge me every day
to be a better teacher,
a better mentor.
They have an enormous enthusiasm
for conquering the world.
Many come in to research,
excited but a little bit unsure
of themselves.
And there's usually a moment
when things just click.
And they realize that they
know enough to come up
with a new solution
to a problem.
And seeing them find that
confidence is so much more
thrilling than any
scientific discovery
that I have had so
far in my career.
[MUSIC PLAYING]